what's up guys it's anthony unofficial i
am a retired poker player and ex-child
actor wow great
yeah that's good that's it that is
awesome well first of all anthony
welcome to the podcast this has been a
long time coming and what's cool about
this is that you and i met probably 10
years it's probably been 10 years yeah i
bet 10 years ago from lotuses yeah
anthony and i both had lotuses we're
both on lotustalk.com
we became friends from one of the car
meets and just kept in touch ever since
yeah the good old lotus forums but this
is a really cool podcast because i feel
like you have such an interesting story
and a lot of insights into the world of
playing professional poker
sure uh i mean yeah after well it was
really i was acting
and you know you go on auditions during
the week and stuff and then i had my
weekends open i started coming to vegas
at 21
and i realized i liked poker i liked the
aspect of it where
the psychological and because i was an
actor
i sort of you know i could get into
character and so on the weekends i would
be playing a character just like i would
be when i was auditioning or on set
and you really do you can't be yourself
especially if you're
too nice or you don't like to take money
off like if that's a problem for you
don't play
you got to get cutthroat with it you got
to be you know fu type of thing because
otherwise uh the worst thing you could
do is have somebody crushed and you'll
see this happen too in high stakes games
where people will actually give you
they'll say okay i had you crushed there
let's just chop the pot which means no
way yeah so let's say you have somebody
crushed like i have pocket aces you have
pocket kings pre-flop we get all the
money in and i go
jack can't afford like i i don't want to
do this to you
you couldn't afford the 50 g's we put in
each right pre-fly
we got it all in jack thought he had me
with kings
woofs you flipped the kings i go
gotcha jack i got aces and i go
i don't want to do this to you man why
don't we just chop the blinds so graham
let's say would have been big blind here
let's say we were playing uh were we
playing 200 400 no limit graham had the
big blind at 400. so what we're gonna do
is we're gonna chop the pod we're going
to chop graham's 400.
so you each get 200 yeah so we need to
get it nice yeah and then so graham gets
screwed over here but i didn't hurt you
right but at the same time i was only 80
to win the hand so really you did have a
20 chance of win but if you think about
it you put in 50 grand i put it in 50
grand you're way behind like that's not
good that's not a good spot for you
great spot for me but then again one in
five times you hit a king or you hit
running cards and make a straight or
something crack my aces that's cracking
the ace yeah
so at the same time i'm not taking the
risk that one in five chance right that
makes sense so you know uh but anyway
what was my point oh you got to be
cutthro so really if we sat down and
played and you said i got 50 g's anthony
let's do this what i would say okay and
then if i get it all in with you i have
aces dude we're running it you know
we're running it that's the way that's
just the way i would you wouldn't feel
bad for me or anything you just take it
off not in because you knew i know
you're right you're right yeah yeah
absolutely yeah so
how many times have you seen it in
situations like that where the person is
just devastated afterwards do do people
ever feel bad afterwards and like oh you
lost but okay let me give you some back
does that happen so the true pros i i
mean they know they know the ebb and
flow they're so good that really at the
end of every year like they're up money
in a typical year and that includes
let's say they went three months of red
they were in the red for three straight
months then they maybe had a couple good
months one bad month four or five good
you know you'd call that running good
you run good for a while sometimes you
run back and you have to be able to
withstand that i tell everybody this
some people do ask me for advice even
though i haven't played seriously in
like nine years people will ask me
they'll say like you know i really i
want to make a go at it and i tell them
okay you have to be able to withstand
months it's tough of just losing and
again this would be okay let's go back
to the aces against king's hand let's
say you're only supposed to lose that
one in five times if you get it all in
pre-flop what if you lose that like
three times in a row that's not supposed
to happen so statistically you should be
able to lose one and then win the next
four times you get the you know 80 20
could be jacks against tens uh you know
tens against threes like i'm supposed to
crush you on all those hands
about one out of five times i'm not but
what if i lose three or four of those in
a row you start you go how can i how can
i do this like i'm doing everything
right and i'm still losing and that's
the interesting thing about poker is you
can play at a very high level you're
playing perfectly sometimes you sit down
you don't make a single mistake like you
look back you you lose for the session
that session gone you're out and you
walk away and you go i did everything
right
and yet i i lost and then it'll happen
to you the next night and the next night
and weeks can go by and you start
questioning everything
and so i told you you you know give it a
try and see some people are able to just
stick it out and everybody goes broke by
the way so i think that's part of the
answer to that question is you got to be
ready to go broke look at doyle brunson
look at any of the greats they'll tell
you they went broke countless times joy
brunson look it up he probably went
broke like a hundred times i mean
something unfathomable to most people
like he's
dead dead bro has to start from from the
beginning so that's the thing is you'll
like move up in stakes as you get better
as your winnings you know grow you go up
in stakes and then when you go broke
unless you can borrow money which
typically you get to know players
they'll loan you money if they know
you're good if they know you like i know
you would loan me you know a lot of
money right now so
that's great um but that'll help you get
back too got it but assuming you can't
get a lot i mean you got to start from
whatever whatever you got uh you know
edd you got to take that and then
try to grow it back you know whatever
whatever you got to do you got to do got
it now let's start from the very
beginning because you said child acting
oh yeah how did you get started in that
or my friend childhood i grew up with
this dude he lived two blocks from me
and he was two years older than me so he
was two i was a baby we just now he was
acting since he was a baby so we're
talking kindergarten cop like movies
you've seen yeah he's been in him from
the 90s from the 80s 90s
so by the time i was nine i had said i
want to do this because i saw him in
commercials and everything i thought was
so cool
so i told my dad now my dad had done
commercial acting in the 70s and he had
basically retired by the 80s when i was
born but he knew how to do it get an
agent and get head shots and then you
just start auditioning so he'd take me
to auditions it just so happened i
booked my first audition which was for
the role of linus in the peanuts gang
now this was just supposed to be like
one they needed you you know for a
commercial yeah it was a metlife
commercial so i played linus i went in i
just read i don't know i could read good
i could read good you know so i read the
lines and it was just it was so easy and
i had the pure like linus is supposed to
have sort of a pure now my voice has
changed obviously my voice has changed
and that's when i lost the role so i had
it from 9 to 15. but it turned into all
kinds of stuff supposed to be the
commercial but it's sort of like once
you prove yourself like if you're good
on the first one they're just like okay
you're lying this now like wow for a
while that hit you to be linux is
because charlie brown is huge she's been
huge for decades yeah did you did that
concept stick with you back then that
you realized like this is linus yo uh
charles schultz was the bomb i mean
that's when it it got real
but did i i knew of peanut butter you
know at nine years old i just sort of i
knew charlie brown and snoopy and you
know watch the movies and stuff but once
i met charles schultz and i got to be 10
11 and he was such a cool guy by the way
he would get all the the voice actors
all the kids would get christmas gifts
from him every year and like it was just
it was he was like your grandpa because
i didn't know either of my grandpas like
so uh that was kind of cool to like have
it he was just the nicest guy
yeah so very cool experiences definitely
at that like a dream job at any age
but to be making money and having so
much fun at nine ten years old how much
can can you say how much
megan
it was pretty good i mean i did
couple movies i guess
the thing i don't even know like i look
back at the resume you can imdb me and i
go
it was so much fun you did they just
bring you in they'd show you the lines
you just read the line i didn't even
know what projects they were for
sometimes
cd roms or cd-roms this is how yeah this
is a long time ago so uh commercials the
commercials are lucrative so you're
saying like how much did i make off
being linus
i mean it was six figures right there
yeah at that age and then of course a
lot of that is put away like your
parents legally have to put a lot of
that away for you
jeanette mccurdy we had her on she said
that they only had to put away 15
percent now the other 85 percent the
parents can spend however they want but
they would hope that it would wind it
back and like you know housing and stuff
like this
sounds right i would not disagree i
don't know the exact figure
i think my parents were cool i think it
was probably a lot higher because my
parents were
they wanted me to have a college fund or
you know the poker fund is really what
it is
but um
at nine years old they're like you know
what he needs a poker fund when he's 21
he's going to go to vega he's going to
gamble it all brilliant yeah
they were great like that but you took
the initiative after seeing your
neighbor doing that
then you decided that you wanted to
become a voice actor i just wanted to do
i really wanted to be a race car driver
my mom wouldn't let my dad so my dad
raced cars too he res he raced scca in
the 70s he was really good and i kind of
had the bug because he had a lot of cool
cars
and i remember what telling him that and
he just sort of he let me down easy and
i remember the conversation where he
just said look mom is gonna let you and
i found out later it was because my mom
he knew if something happened to me yeah
it would have been divorced it would
have been like my mom would have never
forgiven him so he was like i don't
really want to get divorced like i don't
want that to potentially happen let's
try to keep anthony a little bit safer
and just let him act to protect the
marriage
i think it was a really good marriage
yeah
but they knew either you're going to be
good at it but to protect the marriage i
could have been yeah that could have
been the next lewis
anyway but that would have been fun but
acting was great too i have to say but i
want to know like what about your voice
made you so good for lions and this is
your first audition right i would say
it's that purity so if you if you look
at charlie brown sure he's got more like
the horse yeah yeah yeah yeah that so i
i would have never been charlie brown
yeah and that's just genetics i mean you
there was
unless you can create that but at that
age they didn't want that at that age
what charles schultz would look for is
just
like you speak right now and he'd say
maybe you're good for this voice or
you're just not oh you didn't even know
you're going in for linus you were just
going in i think i went in but this was
a long time ago jack but like i think
they just they gave you some lines and
they had you read them and they'd be
like and there was a casting director
too before charles ever heard you the
cast nerd would be like okay you sound
like a linus you know and then they give
you maybe more of the linus lines
instead of just the generic lines yeah
you read a few linus lines and then they
send it like to charles was like okay
but it was it was quick like he made he
didn't mess around he made a decision
fast i remember knowing like that night
that i got it can you can you say a
linus line in your linus voice
oh man you got me yeah i haven't even
watched this stuff that's the crazy you
didn't watch it after you were no no i
mean like in years oh okay i haven't
watched this stuff in two decades so i
would love to but it'll just be some bs
that i'm creating right now try it
um
no linus wouldn't say that oh gosh
charlie brown
oh my goodness
let's go over here charlie brown it was
it was always really interesting
very innocent character you know totally
the opposite of me right now
[Laughter]
geez so so how did that evolve then from
charlie brown into other projects
so once you break into voice acting and
man is it a tight circle and again this
was my friend who i grew up with
uh if you break and you're on a couple
shows what happens is
they tend to hire people who are proven
and it's tough there's so much talent
just in la the talent pool is so extreme
that you've got here's the big circle of
talented people that are out there and
then here's the one of people already
working the only way you break in from
being killer and if you're not killer
talented don't don't waste your time
right
so you got to be good and then okay
maybe give it a shot try to get an agent
now what you'll end up doing is if the
agent you know you send in your demo or
a lot of times now youtube if you can do
voices and stuff put them on youtube and
be like here's me doing batman here's me
and people will search to search you out
because they may not want to pay the guy
who does the spot on batman who's
already making a g every time he says a
lion as batman they may let's say it's a
low budget you know project and they
want to pay a hundred bucks they might
go on ebay and be like that guy that's
pretty good batman how about a hundred
bucks you know boom and you can break in
that way now but let's okay let's say
this is an old school wave you get an ag
make a demo tape with all your voices or
it's a commercial tape and you get an
agent now the agent is going to take you
on because maybe their top people are
working so much
if you're in that the the inner circle
you're working all the time and it very
lucrative okay so the agent's going to
say bob is working every day this week i
can't even he doesn't have to have time
to audition but let's take on so and so
okay we'll take you on and now you're
gonna get those auditions when bob is
busy
and now you got to deliver you gotta
nail it and if you're good you're gonna
start you know booking work
and now the more you book the more
proven you become and you enter that
inner circle that's my best way of
explaining voice acting voice acting is
probably the toughest niche i'm just
going to say it it's the toughest niche
of the entertainment industry to break
into and start working but once you are
working and you're proven
golden beautiful i bet it's because so
many people are so versatile with their
voices so i've seen so it's it's almost
every voice actor does like seven
characters
per show oh yeah it's been really cool
to watch uh even a lot of the voices of
the rugrats
do multiple characters same with the
simpsons
uh they they do at least five to seven
eight different characters on the
simpsons and a small group of like four
people can do voices of 30 people there
you go and think about it the more
versatile you are the more likely you
get you're gonna get to get hired
because they can have you now you're in
the booth already they're paying the
same money and it's like okay yeah do
the other voice and hear the other lines
hear the other lines why would you want
to hire that out to like the simpsons
they'd need 20 people yeah but now they
don't because
and you didn't change your voice at all
for linus or did you change it so i hit
puberty
and it was all over how sad were you to
hit puberty
because you knew that that would be like
the end of your did you ever think that
like i could delay this dude it's like
it hits you and it says i went in and i
remember them being um they were a
little like disappointed sad i don't
know what emotion but you could feel it
in the room where they knew
and they put out the casting call and
that's it oh did what did they tell you
did they
just never get called again are you
serious you know the entertainment
industry you don't get but but you don't
think that like from nine to how old
were you
fifteen i made it to fifteen fifteen so
from nine to fifteen so you've been
working with him as a child for six
years and i think that last year started
interrupting but that last year i think
i was try i was like fake it you can
still oh
trying to raise your boy you know i know
i was but you don't think that after six
years of working with relatively the
same group of people that they would sit
you down and be like hey
uh your voice is changing thank you
here's a gift
best of luck like we have other projects
no they were so nice though you can't
hold that again the entertainment street
is you know it's all about yes you gotta
there's no time for that okay i mean
really if if we're facing fast they just
gotta move on and it happens every so
often when the voice actors age out it's
just a normal thing for them it's not
you know to you as the actor it's a
bigger deal so you knew this was coming
oh yeah i mean
so now it's coming back to me i haven't
thought about this in a long time that i
was faking because you don't want to
lose the game that's right and i
remember talking with my dad and yeah
sure we had all those discussions okay
make sure you raise your but keep your
voice
when you're not doing the line like you
wouldn't want to be going oh no charlie
brown and then be like cool guys or we
don't you know what
so so you gotta be baking your shirt the
whole way and then but they could tell
at a certain point they know you know
i'm sure a lot of voice actors go
through that then yeah the younger ones
like they have to fake their voice and
everything being a child actor is a trip
because now we could move into what
happens with you on camera and so some
kids are cute
this sounds really i don't know if i'm
being too blunt they're cute when
they're kids and now they're 15 16 18
and maybe
i mean i'm not gonna say they're not
cute anymore or you know at but they
don't have whatever the it factor was
that made them good for projects as a
kid as a child all of a sudden it's like
oh so and so is 18 now and you come out
and they go i remember you from whatever
the movie was home alone you know
and now i don't know about you at this
stage right who's the who's the kid from
the sixth sense he's the first one that
comes to mind
but he's been on some stuff he has now
he has yeah he's get he's getting it
going yeah completely different
character yeah yeah so it's never over
but for me at a certain point then i
retired at like 32. i said look i stuck
it out in my 20s but i would say my
career started in my 20s you know just i
could see the work drying up
and that's not to say now perseverance
is is high up on the list of what you
need to succeed as an actor that could
be number one i mean it might be above
talent
i don't know talent talent for sure
and of course like luck and timing i
mean you figure everybody who's become
something you look at like their
breakthrough and you go if that movie if
that project wasn't made at that point
in time they mean they may have never
made it so you do need some luck and but
i would say perseverance is key because
not everybody makes it at 18 20 years
not everybody makes it at 30. look at
john hamm uh you know so
i don't know i at a certain point though
i just had to say i'll move on i had a
good time i did everything that you
could probably hope to do really right
is if you're not greedy i mean stage
voice acting commercials i was on a
sitcom i was in a feature film with
bruce willis
you got a name dropped now can you tell
us about these projects okay so that
movie was banned it's 2001 bruce willis
billy bob doran directed by barry
levinson kate blanchett
so killer cast that's a lot of fun if
you need a date movie from the early
2000s
yes highly recommend it um check me out
in that with azura sky
we're making out on the couch azura was
great you were looking i was 16 when we
shot that yeah
i forget but
somewhere around there
and uh yeah we're making out and bruce
was about to break out of prison spoiler
alert but you should still watch the
movie but i can tell you that they break
out of prison they come into this house
because they're trying to lose the cops
they pull into the garage garage door
closes cops go by now they come into the
house we're making out on the couch they
walk in and we're surprised and okay now
go watch the movie
so
forced into essentially like a make-out
scene i had to make out with azure skype
how many takes did you ever stop yeah
can we do another barry can we do
another take one more take yeah i messed
up a little bit hold on
i need to get in character here
yeah
sorry that light is really distracting
me over there if we could just
let's talk more about the makeout scene
so like was it awkward like was it
comfortable was that the only makeout
scene you've ever had
yeah it was the only one
it's like it's clinical i mean it's
rolling
action
and
you start making out but it's cool i'm
not i can't say it's bad it's like you
know but you don't have exactly the
emotions and you're thinking about you
know you're trying to be stay in
character and then of course they
interrupt us and then we're gonna panic
and so you know you just try to take it
second by second but i would say there
are a couple seconds where you're you're
kind of into it right i mean as you
might be yeah come on yeah
so how many times were you uh did you
have to do that
uh how many takes yeah i think five or
six wow
yeah imagine if they just started
casting you as the guy that makes out
yeah oh my god yeah and they would they
had playback too so it was rolling
playback so they had music like pumping
yeah during the scene
because the vibes have to be right on
some of these projects they won't
they'll just add it in later so there's
actually no music when you're shooting
scene but we had playback and it was led
zeppelin which they didn't end up using
they couldn't get it it was gonna be too
much money or they just couldn't get it
but it the vibes were very uh intense so
great experience how did she feel about
that
she was great uh i gotta say though
consummate professional you know i mean
uh she was just really on point
everybody almost that i've ever worked
with i don't have that many disaster
stories about like all this actors
really
i don't know i was in that's why i said
i can't ever complain i never say uh
acting but i never talk because how
could i
she was so on point everybody on set on
that set
we could go into other projects if you
want about some of the the best actors
i've worked with these people are any
field that you're in and you you look up
to people i mean i worked with some of
my heroes basically so
really cool stuff and she's she's like
who
so i would have to go back to jon hamm
mad men i was lucky enough to get a
recurring on mad men in like five
episodes
this guy uh
he was there before everybody every day
every day i would be i'd come in i
thought i was early his car's there
i would leave late his car is there this
guy never flubbed a line and if you
watch the show you know
he had dialogue he had some serious
dialogue he's in almost every scene of
the show
and this guy
just knowing his lines right away you
gotta give somebody some respect you
never saw him on book like
i never saw him looking at anything just
bam locked in
and then
man when they would say
even before rowling like you could just
see him he'd he'd be in character like
and i don't know if he was method or
anything
but
so
locked in and the respect i have for
people like that it's unreal every scene
that i saw him do or was lucky enough to
be in one scene got cut which was
unfortunate because we had a couple
lines back and forth that would have
been cool so i was sad to see that that
get cut but the guy is to me the the
pinnacle of like being great at your job
he took it so seriously and it and it
comes through let's face it you watch
the show but it wasn't one of those
things where like oh that was a lucky
take like oh he was in it that taken
they used that one every take i saw from
him you could have used
just uh
yeah i would rank him as high up as you
could ever get
but it's not just talent see it's work
ethic i think he has both the people who
have both in any industry right those
are the the top you're going to be
successful
what about bloopers would would those
ever happen while you're recording like
funny bloopers or people will start
laughing
mess around on that set if you had seen
some of the blue which i saw at so like
red wrap parties they would either do
they'd stage like a funny thing on video
and show it like for the creator matt
winer and you can find this on youtube
well i haven't looked at this in years
we actually sang a song
and it was supposed to be for matt winer
the creator mad men just for his eyes
only that's what they told us for his
eyes only and we sang bye bye birdie
song from the 60s you can look this up
right now put like mad men bye-bye
birdie into youtube well not right now
finish watching it and then the episode
okay after the episode and you'll see me
in there and we're all singing bye bye
birdie they cut it all together and then
it gets put on youtube like wait a
second i didn't sign up for this
but luckily i was pretty good i think i
was all right so they would do funny
stuff like that and i remember at one of
the wrap parties they cut together a lot
of bloopers
uh of people running around set naked
and like it was if you saw that one now
that i don't think is on youtube but you
could try to find it but uh that was
pretty wild so that's the thing about
acting is it was really so much fun
um it doesn't feel like work most of the
time
what about method actors you you
mentioned that like have you had any
experience with that and explain what
method actors is for anyone who may not
know you're basically staying in
character the entire time so when you're
on set uh this would be like christian
bale as batman okay you don't hear him
uh he he's not british you would think
he's american i mean he stays in it and
that can help by the way when you're
doing an accent or something like that
you don't want to be jumping back and
forth typically because now it's like
action you're like
do the australian accent
um that's usually where you'll see but
some actors are all the way uh daniel
day lewis would be a great example i
mean and these are people where you
can't argue
with it even if they're a holes like
because they're so in character all the
time you're like what is it with this
guy but if it's gonna resonate with an
audience and if that's what's gonna get
you to that upper echelon that daniel
day-lewis um you know uh
i don't know
it's worth it i think
and
i never did it
but i could see where the payoff
could be massive
so how did you transition from that to
21 then poker
so i started playing poker on the
weekends i would act i would do you know
audition everything during the week
i'd drive to vegas and i tried to
calculate how many trips have i made to
vegas in my life well a lot of times i
was going every weekend like every
weekend so it'll be like 52 weekends a
year that's
what 52 round trip drives and i like to
drive and really like to fly so that's
hundreds i've made hundreds of trips
telling to me that la to vegas is just
like
here we go again yeah just uh automatic
at this point so i started doing that
and i started making more money playing
poker than i made as an actor let's
let's
pause there for a second how did you
learn how to play poker at what age were
like oh i wanna because i don't think
you just pick up at 21 and say hey i'm
gonna play poker this weekend and then
just keep going back yeah i started
playing online for sure i remember
bulldog
bulldog.com was one of my favorite sized
poker stars oh man these sides back in
the day this was uh i don't know it's
different now you know um i definitely
played a lot online but i wasn't that
good online but i learned the game my
grandmother is partially responsible for
my love of cards in general used to play
cards with her and i would beat her
occasionally as a kid and she would get
pissed what would she be what would you
say
and these other random games that to
this day i asked like my uncle i'm like
what was that game yeah and he sort of
he sometimes tells me and then i forget
again but random games and i just always
loved cards oh video poker she loved
video poker too and she had these little
the handheld video every grandma has
that by the way i remember going to my
grandma's house a little
battery-operated one there it is it
would flip open and it was like it was
just the one game pretty much i think it
was like nobody would know what it was
yeah i remember that
yeah oh wow we should get one of those
i bet they're on ebay yeah
okay that could be the one of the best
ways to learn poker yeah
little video handheld yeah so i mean i
at least knew the hands right i knew
pear through royal flush and everything
so that was good and then i started
playing it just organically started to
happen i can't tell you was there like a
a moment of clarity where i said this is
it no i built up uh and just started
playing really low stakes i remember
playing two four limit that means you
can't raise more than four dollars i
mean you know like the big blind would
be four dollars i could raise to eight
dollars
so that's a good way though
if i'm laughing about that i just mean
that that's where i started and it's
kind of funny but i wouldn't laugh at
anybody if they said that's what they
were going to go play great way to learn
um get on the grind i mean if you think
you want to take a shot at it start
grinding and then see that's the only
way to really find out i imagine that's
similar in every career acting again if
you really want to give it you you got
to go for it you'll never know if you
don't try
so you realize then you came to vegas
that you had a knack for playing this
game at a certain point yeah i started
realizing i was winning a lot
and i was like this is cool i like the
the money
i like the money uh yeah but it also
it's rewarding so like acting sure very
rewarding i mean uh it's it's cool when
you walk away and you say man i played
killer
it's a good feeling even even if you
aren't up that much money you still you
know uh
it feels good about that
your self-esteem yeah what were some of
those early games like do you have any
stories from back then or like things
that you tripped up about or players
that you played with back then yeah i
played with some some pretty uh cool
players i'd say min lie is one of my
favorite dudes uh if you do the accent
daniel negrano does the accent really
well um
he's just he's funny like the guy again
very serious like when he plays but when
he's not playing like great dude great
dude to hang with and um i've actually
played back raw with him too which is a
dangerous thing i want to say like why
did i stop if we want to jump there why
did i retire it's because i played table
games too much and that can be dangerous
because you're not you're at a
disadvantage when you play tables the
house edge will grind you out so what
would happen is a lot of times i would
win big playing poker because i would
have the advantage if you play well
enough you have the advantage you're
gonna maybe win
and then you go to these
tables roulette craps whatever
and now you're playing at a disadvantage
over time you just can't win you're
gonna lose and so when that started
happening to me too much uh i just had
to wrap it up i'm i'm bad at around
casinos
so that's not to say i still don't go
it's still something that i battle with
and uh you know you try to have fun i
would say
set your limits all the the cliches yeah
right now about but um
yeah i played with some cool people
and by the way very helpful uh like if
you have questions just start talking to
some players especially away from the
table
at the table at the table hey man is
this hand good yeah what do you think of
that
don't do that you know what you have put
away from the table you can ask you can
ask for advice and everything and a lot
of especially i was young right and as
playing with guys 30s 40s and it's the
typical like mentor type relationship if
you play with these dudes long enough
they will want to see you
succeed i mean as long as you're not
beating them yeah you know but still um
how many of those guys are full-time
versus how many were just coming on a
weekend
play here and there and leave a lot of
full-time relatives
so that's why i had to start saying
it should i keep acting but again i kept
saying oh the perseverance thing i was
like i'll just if i stay in it and i can
do both and i managed to make that work
pretty well i think it was in retrospect
probably the wrong decision if i could
do it over again i would have bought a
house out here in the late 2000s
especially when the market i mean you
could pick stuff up for dirt sheep out
here
so i could have picked something up and
taken it really seriously and gone seven
days a week or six days and
you know one day and
just and done it as a career i think
that's where i messed up is i tried to
do both and i think maybe that's good
advice for most careers if you really
want to succeed you want to be the top
in something you got to go at it full
time you got to take it seriously what's
the mental toll that takes on you though
to do gambling full time like that
gambling could be one of the most
stressful i know there are a lot of
stressful jobs that people are going to
be offended right now my job is
stressful yeah
but it's got to be it's
up there we're talking top five top 10
most stressful doc you'd have to say
professional poker professional gambler
in general um also it's the swings okay
you work let's say a typical
quote-unquote job you're gonna make
money that day when you go home at the
end of the day you've locked in that
income you made that money it's gonna
come to you you're done
in poker yeah you made okay oh you just
came home from the tables you made money
what's gonna happen tomorrow you're
putting that money back at risk and you
can lose so the swings are massive like
i said everybody goes broke and prepare
yourself every when i say everybody
everybody you're gonna go bro especially
starting out you'll never just go oh i
started with a thousand dollars and i've
never looked back no just does not
happen
how many times have you gone broke
uh
and can you give us an example run us
through a story of one time where you
weren't broke and then you went broke
and then you got out of being broke
okay well so i've never thought of the
exact number but it has to be around
five six seven times you know not
anything
totally crazy but yeah when you go broke
it's sort of like you had a bankroll
together you know typically in cash cash
and chips
let's say you built it up to 50 grand
and man that can go fast if you're
playing at high enough stakes that can
be your buy-in you can buy in for 50 g's
things go bad again i i get the kings
this time and jack has his 50 g's here
and he wipes me out and i just went
broke because what if i brought that was
my entire bankroll that i brought here
and i'm gonna get jack
jack said not today and now i just went
broke
and you got to find the money somewhere
now so luckily okay if you have a second
income so with acting i'd get residual i
still to this day get residuals from
stuff like
you know
a bug's life i was in some
stuff that still makes millions of
dollars so you get a little cut of that
because you were in it you get residuals
and so just even from things like that
and you can take that money and again
build it up so you got to start then i
can't play jack for 50k again but i can
go back to the casino and play some 2-4
and try to make a thousand and a 10 and
then i'm coming for you jack i'm coming
for you again you know and then maybe
next time you you get up to a hundred
and you get up to 200. yeah but now see
you you tend to raise the stakes or at
least i did in general you go up in
stakes the bigger your bankroll gets and
so then the risk is there you could have
and you're not supposed to do that but
it happens where you take your entire
bank roll or let's say you got 100k and
you play 20. that's still too high but
it happens you'll do it you'll convince
yourself i'm gonna go for it and now you
lose that 20 you go okay
next night another 20. lose that and
it's those losing streaks and it happens
to everybody and what you're hoping to
do is build up enough of a bankroll to
where you can withstand twenty one night
twenty the next night twenty the next
night and then you'll have a big night
and you'll make it all back plus
twenty forty and now you're up to a
hundred and you so you had sixty you had
some bad night whatever it was
and you're just trying to at the end of
the year
the bankroll should be bigger than it
was at the beginning of the year what's
the biggest loss that you've seen
six figures have heavy six figures
yeah and
when you really see pros they take it
like it's just another day at the job
and that's how you have to be with it
i remember seeing chris ferguson um
and this dude is a mathematician i mean
genius
but that's not enough with him it's he's
a genius
and he can manage his emotions because
if he didn't have that it doesn't matter
how smart you are you have to have your
emotions in check and this dude can take
uh
you know he can take a loss for sure
and
just bounces right back it's just it's
just a bad day at work but you know hey
yeah reminds me of a story i i saw this
recently actually on youtube this came
up recommended for me about the luckiest
guy in vegas
forget who this guy's name was uh we
could put him up on the screen here yeah
i think he went from like zero yeah i
think he started with like a thousand
bucks yeah grew that to like 40 million
dollars over the course of a few years
uh you would think he would stop didn't
stop
went on a losing streak
lost it all borrowed ten thousand
dollars from somebody else
did it again yeah he got 30 million
dollars the second time
and instead of just walking away he kept
playing it
and then he went down to zero and has
not been able to recover
i'm gonna say imagine that yeah archie
karis is that maybe hold on
if i look how close that sounds i
googled it and it just said archie
charis boom yeah that was him cool yeah
archie karis great guy yeah the days
that saw archie cares turned fifty
dollars into 40
million
dollars from 50 bucks
50 bucks jack that means if you have 50
bucks right now we could turn that into
40 million dollars i can do it right now
right now well it'll take a few years
it'll take you but you got to just keep
winning just keep winning but you have
to think too like the statistical odds
it's got to happen to somebody someone
at some point will just go on that lucky
streak where everything they do and i
think it's his is just him keep he just
keeps pressing and pressing and it just
worked in his favor until it didn't what
a story yeah and i think
i think he lost it all in like two three
weeks i mean
like four years where the work was gone
like that just in a bad losing streak
and it can happen like yeah when you hit
a bad losing streak
oh yeah and he said it affected his
health unfortunately and that's what i'm
talking about when i say it's one of the
most stressful oh yeah you're under i
mean because that money you it's it's
the you can lose it all it's not
something else where you can either oh
you have a bad day you didn't make any
money how about you can lose everything
you work for for years in a day in an
hour
that's stress
yeah
how would you say uh gambling and all
that has affected you over the years
i've got some gray hairs jack i've uh
you know they're starting to yeah it
started to happen um
i don't know it's sort of like if you
could live another life i'd probably
have lived something
um less dramatic you know it would be
fun to have that but you only have one
like yolo baby you know let's do this so
i figured i would just go with my
passions and
um i don't know it's not boring i'll
tell you that much
so
i can't say i've had a boring life
whatever i might complain about that
wouldn't be a complaint
so what would you say then to people who
want to get in to playing professional
poker
start small you could play online play
with friends learn the game
read some books again doyle brunson is a
bad place to start watch some youtube
videos uh daniel negranu
killer genius dude kid poker
um watch youtube videos
and read books and play play play play
play your ass off the more you play
you're always going to keep learning so
talk to any pro and they're going to
tell you they're still learning it's a
game you will never like master you're
never like okay i got it down
so
uh after a certain point maybe move to
the casino play with money you can
afford to lose ideally and if you go
broke
go broke with okay well that was my
poker bankroll and maybe you still got
some money in the bank that would be
good yeah um but i mean it happens where
people are playing with literally their
lives like they're going for it's it's
all at risk and when they go broke
they really go bro you know i mean
they're begging for
why do you think you were such a good
player
i think it was the acting it was the
fact that i always looked at it as i'd
get into character
and i knew i knew i had to i couldn't be
anthony at least the anthony i was in my
early 20s because i was probably too
nice i just wasn't gonna go for it so
and i learned that early on like i i'm
not gonna say i was winning immediately
i definitely was not
and then i realized like okay i gotta
dress the part because how i normally
dress is just t-shirt and i derp around
i love to you know be comfortable but
dressing the part
it helps every drug helps give us some
examples how do you dress you could do
the sunglasses although you know now
that's more looked upon as like who's
the d bag with
sunglasses i assume that that was like
still a thing like you'd put on the
sunglasses and the hat and the the the
headphones and just kind of choose some
gum
sure uh yeah the headphones is a thing
um you know look the part uh otherwise
you're you're a marked man too out there
you don't want to look like a tourist
although maybe you could look like dirt
that's the other thing switching gears i
was always good at that that's the term
for your playing aggressive one minute
and they look at you as this guy's
raising every hand
and now
you tighten up
and so i was always good at switching
gears that was definitely something that
came naturally to me and that can throw
people off just the second they think
they've got your number
you switch it up
and uh it can throw people because
you're always trying to get a read i
mean we could go in a little bit of
poker strategy you're trying to get a
read on the person and that's where my
acting background is good i was good at
reading people because
emotions i'd been in acting classes
since i was
that young 9 10 years old
so
i was good at managing my emotions and
also throwing people off i could
make it happen to where it seemed
natural if i looked a little stressed i
could do it in such a way where i'm
really not stressed i got you i got you
right now you're drawing dead i got a
full house i got quads on you
but i'd make it seem like maybe i don't
and it's subtle
very subtle because the second you
overdo it and you try to act stress away
typically now that's a tell that means
that you have a big hand and you're
trying to look stressed
so there's a fine line and if you can
walk that fine line
you could be a top player
so what would you do if you got a bad
hand
fold
what kind of question is that no
bluff
bluff what are you talking about you got
a question so you gotta you got jack's
option and you got graham i know what
jack would do now we have a play
play
we got him all in
i played for seven hours i played poker
with anthony sometimes he would have the
worst hands but go all in and you would
just immediately like i don't i don't
want to mess with this that's because
you probably play super tight so knowing
knowing who graham is he probably plays
super tight well this is great because
what we're getting to is you can't be
scared money this is another great point
so that money if that's your rent money
on the line you're a screw you're in bad
shape because also you're gonna know
what the decision nine times out of ten
even as a beginning player you're gonna
have that intuition you know what the
right decision is
can you pull the trigger you know you
should go all in against jack and make
him fold can you do it what if that's
the rent money you're gonna say to
yourself i know i should pull the
trigger because i can get him to fold
but what if what if i'm wrong
there's a one percent chance he has even
though i'm 99 sure
and you can't do it and you fold that
means by the way you're playing too high
state or you shouldn't be playing at all
yeah
don't be scared money i have taken i've
i've killed people uh not literally but
i've killed them financially the people
you smoke are typically scared money
whoa uh they're in bad shape because if
you're not yeah you're gonna be making
all the right you make all the right
decisions i'm not all the right but like
you're gonna follow through on what you
think is the right decision
far more than they are
have you ever seen someone lose a huge
hand and then just freak out
yeah
uh definitely i've been called every
name in the book um
probably most names in the book by
people who
usually it's when you put a bad beat on
someone so a bad beat would be
want to do it one more time
i got the kings and you have the aces
pre-flop
you're 80 percent to win that hand if we
get all the money in pre-flop pl oh by
the way pre-flop means like in texas
hold them and by the way we're talking
about no limit texas holding here that's
the game that's the cadillac of poker
that's all i really ever played there
are many other games and a lot of the
top players play a multitude of games
raz you can they're really cool games
but
in no limit texas hold'em pre-flop means
that all of us if it's the three of us
let's say we're three-handed which means
just three of us at a table we each get
two community cards well graham let's
say folds irae grandfath and now it goes
to you you go all in and i go well i
have kings and that would be i have two
kings because those are my two cards you
have two aces and we get it all in
you're 80
to win with the aces if i crack your
aces so let's say i flop a king and the
flop is the first three cards so let's
say it's king
five deuce and then it the run out like
the turn and river so there will end up
being five community cards total
and let's say the turn is a three and
the river's a ten okay nothing much
happened there other than i hit my king
so i made a set of kings three kings
trip kings and i cracked your races
because you only ended up you're gonna
play the top five cards out of the total
seven cards you're gonna play the five
highest cards i'm gonna obviously play
my three kings you can only play your
two aces you didn't improve so your pair
of aces loses to trip king so i beat you
you might freak out i don't know i don't
know how would you freak out you might
yeah because it was like statistically
very improbable right yeah but it
happened yeah that that reminds me of
one time where i was playing and i had i
was dealt pocket queens and uh i kept
raising the pot because like the flop
came and i still had the best hand they
were all you know significantly lower no
chance of a straight no chance of a
flush and i raised a little bit and then
it went around most people folded and
then it was like me and this one other
guy after like uh the turn came or
whatever like then it was it was just me
and this one other guy okay and um heads
up yeah and it was heads up okay and i
was feeling good and i raise again yeah
and um so i think i'd raise three times
pre pre-flop flop and then you know turn
or whatever and then uh you know so four
chords four four cards are out and then
uh what happens i yeah like i said i
raised he called and then the final card
came and it was a king
okay and i was like okay
yeah so i was like okay so what's what's
happening now and then i'm like i'm like
uh okay and then i go a check and then
he goes check and he turns it over and
he has like king seven off suit and i i
show my cards and i was i i was
devastated i knew he had won too i knew
it as soon as the king came and i
remember i was like oh and i leaned back
in my chair and i leaned back a little
too far where the entire chair just fell
over backwards in the dead quiet poker
room
no one's talking it's just me and i lean
back and the entire chair just topples
over how did it feel to lose a dollar
this was like no this is
probably like 250 bucks
and this is when i
was definitely not in the same position
as i am now sure hey it hurts at any
denomination i don't care when you get
rivered it's a gut punch
yeah
yeah it can be brutal yeah
um
what other strategies do you have
because the one thing i learned from you
that one time we played
anthony like and it didn't hit me until
the end of the game
anthony would bet the most random
amounts at like
random times so like just let's say
we're going through he'll throw like 14
or like 17. everyone else is doing like
five 10 15 20 25. and he's like 14
with no limit hold him you can do that
right and i love to throw in that render
even in tournaments oh we didn't discuss
even turn you can play tournaments too
if you want to get into both what's nice
about tournaments is the buy-in let's
say it's a 200 buy-in that's all you can
lose so you have 20 grand in chips or
whatever yeah if you lose that 20 000
it's just tournament chips you're really
only losing your buy-in and then if you
can make it obviously deep in the
tournament the payouts can be huge so we
didn't even touch on that we were
playing i was talking about cash games
this whole time that's another way and
you'll see a lot of the top players make
very good incomes playing tournaments
and then so other people only play cash
games
but yes in so even in a tournament i
love to do that instead of raising to 3
000 i'll raise the 3100 if i have you
know some quarters in there i'll raise
the 31.75
and you can also just say that too that
can be very intimidating so you can just
like
when it's your turn right instead of
a lot of people just like to put the
chips in because they think maybe
they're in their voice there will be a
tell imagine if your voice
it halters or you know
31.75 or you know quivering so some
people but i was always able to be like
3175 and i like to use that too
because sometimes it makes you look like
you're trying to be stronger than you
actually are i'll use it a lot of times
when i'm in a when i have a big hand so
i know i've got the person crushed and
i'll just say it but i won't say it too
strong but just the fact that you even
utter the words
expressing what your bet is will make
people think you're trying to act strong
when you're really not they'll think
it's a bluff so when i say to you i've
been quiet this whole time and the turn
hits and i go
31.75 and i'll say it right to the
dealer too i won't even look at you i'll
go to the dealer so the dealer knows and
without putting the chips in you can say
it and then you throw the chips in but
you'll say i look right at the dealer
and i go
31.75 and i'll put it in but i won't try
to be like 30 once not too strong but
just the fact that i say it and so
the strategies are endless you can play
so many mind games with people and
that's the really fun card apart i've
even done things as weird as
when
i've made a bet
and then
man i've played some really sick stuff
on people now that i think about it so
i'd make a bet and let's say now it's
your turn to act and you're thinking
about it like i bet we're in a
tournament and i bet
5200 on the turn
and now it's your turn to i was first
hacked after the turn right so it's on
you
and now i'll just go into like you know
deep and let's say 5 000 is a lot of
chips at this point in attorney so i'll
be deep in thought now and i won't be
looking at you
and
what i'll do is if you make a motion
towards your chips or something i'll
pretend i've done this a couple times i
don't know if i'm happy about this but
pretend to wince or something you know
so i'll i've thrown the cards in like
all like i'm folding like in other words
like i was bluffing and i thought you
raised out of the corner of my eye but
i'll do it on purpose and so you can do
i don't know you know this isn't
like the best thing to do sure but
you'll do what it takes to win you know
and all like like fold
and now that's folding out of turn like
you're not even allowed right right so
now it'll be like you get the cards back
and now the you'd be totally thrown off
at this point you would think like whoa
anthony thought i raised and he was
ready to just fold to any race he must
not have it
and then
it's happened a couple times where then
i've gotten the money in because the
person thought i had nothing and i've
got like a huge wow
so you can get
really some crazies that's one that i'll
give away wait a second anyway so you
could fold before your turn yeah because
it's on you yeah so i'm not allowed to
fold because i just bet 5g 5000.
so i'm not allowed now to fold until you
act
and but when i fold out a turn like that
the dealer goes uh
he didn't and
i get returned the cards and now you
think that i was scared that you had ray
but use i've only done it when i've seen
like you would make a motion for your
chips or something and i pretend that i
think you just raised so like because
i'm like this and it's like you make a
motion there and i just go like
unfold that's crazy
okay i mean we want more i don't know
yeah that that's me though being deep in
character and that just came to me like
some of these things just happen
naturally i it's not like i sat around
and planned out like what could i really
do other than reading book that's
another reason i would say to read books
you can find out some really cool
strategies that are more just like
that's a rare circumstance that i'm
talking about that happened maybe twice
in how i don't know how many years that
i did that but there are things that you
can utilize on a day-to-day basis like i
talked about switching gears that's one
of the ones i would use every day you
don't want to play aggressive the whole
time you're gonna get eventually they're
gonna be like this guy raises every pot
boom you're gonna get crushed because
they're gonna know the same way if you
play too tight now they know all they
have to do is raise you're gonna fold
anything but pocket aces you can't play
like that
how well do you think dan bilzerian
plays
i've never played with him and i've
heard about him i've heard pros say that
he was not at the level that he said he
was at
um i don't know i i you know i would
have loved to have at least met him at
some point because i think you know cool
character um but
i can't really speak to it you know um
some people probably try to talk about
that they played higher stakes than they
actually played but typically i would
say you can you can tell just by talking
to a person for how long have you been
talking i think you can tell you know
what do you usually look for to see if
they've maybe exaggerated some of their
claims
probably not knowing like terminology
um
not knowing
like where to play where to get into
some of these games
um i feel like if you're an expert on
something you can tell when someone who
isn't an expert is trying to bs
themselves right yeah maybe
have them teach you ask them for advice
i taught you a little bit i remember uh
revving you up one day and just giving
you some quick things like okay well if
you get in this situation don't be
afraid to do this or fold or do whatever
so
um if they don't know how to calculate
pot odds like if they're not good at
math that might be uh you know a
telltale sign i was luckily always
pretty good at math so that was good
that definitely helped me a lot
um but not that you have to be
genius level but if you can just
calculate simple things and you can find
uh tips and tricks so if you don't if
you're not like great at math you can do
things where like all you have to do is
calculate like to calculate percentages
like the 80 20 or let's say we're
already after the turn and i put you on
a hand so you got to also be able to do
that but if i put jack on a specific
hand and i know that well he probably
has four outs well if we've already seen
the turn we only have the river to go
multiply by two and you can get the
percentage of like what he is to win the
hand so if i think he's got like a two
outer like i've got him crushed right
now but there are two kings left and you
have pocket kings there are two kings
left in the deck okay two times
two times two is four percent so he's
like you know four percent to river
and people go how do you know these four
percent to river right there but that's
an easy way to calculate is d times four
for after the flop so he's got a two
hour after the flop two times four eight
percent to win with two cards to come in
it's cool this makes me excited i want
to play poker night damn i'm getting
hyped right now i really want to go to
the department i'm getting hyped let's
play let's play right now
what about what about the uh the table
games do you know how to count cards in
blackjack
no i never learned that uh i tried to
and then i just didn't stick it out um
the problem is that now they've got it
so
the casinos have figured it out i mean
it's very difficult the problem is to
get the good rules you got to be playing
these games that are at least 100
minimum if not like a cosmo 500 minimum
you know and uh now the problem is you
want to raise your bet but ideally you
want to be betting small until you get a
count right so back in the day you could
play five or ten dollars and then when
you get a count you raise it up now you
go to 500. now the problem is you've got
to be playing the good games like with
the good rules you don't want to be
playing six to five blackjack or dealer
hits on soft 17
and you gotta look for the tables with
the good rules the tables with the good
rules have high
minimums and so you've got to be betting
500 a hand until you get a count and now
you get the count and now do you have
the bankroll to okay i've you know i i
have the advantage now i'm gonna bet ten
thousand a hand whatever it would be
fifteen thousand twenty thousand because
you gotta make up too for all the time
you were playing at 500 minimum they've
got it all figured out then they're
gonna see you raising the bet all of a
sudden you were a 500 player and they're
like why did this guy go to ten thousand
all of a sudden by the way they can
count cards too so you've got the floor
pit boss the dealers they can all count
and they do count and by the way they'll
be quizzed on this so at certain points
that that's a test of like the dealers
at any point floor can walk up and say
what's the count to the to the dealer
are you serious this doesn't you don't
hear any of this or you'll see the floor
with the pit boss and you'll see them
talking like like this whatever well
from what i know they will check in with
everybody and say what's the count
especially if i raise my back the second
i go to 10 000 a hand everybody starts
talk you know there's there are things
happening behind the scenes because
guess what that guess what happens once
they think you're counting and they they
go oh he raises better whatever shuffle
they shuffle wow once they shuffle your
account is gone so oh i'm not trying to
deter anybody from counting cards it's
still possible of course to beat the
casinos i'm just saying they've made it
a lot harder they
no is that only are they only counting
cards in the high limit
rooms because i i doubt if you go to the
10 table the person sitting there with
five people like counting cards you want
my opinion yeah every single dealer at a
legit casino
what do you want to say resorts world is
the the new invite win encore
venetian palazzo aria bellagio caesars
go down the line
all the dealers can count
can count but but do they yes
how sometimes it seems like they're
they're bored like you're just
you know they're just doing their things
they're so good
for someone having to talk
it's as natural i would say to good
dealers as us talking english right like
we're not thinking about like the
english language right now we just talk
when they deal they just have the count
like they did sir john they do it every
day that's from what i know
wow
that's insane so is there anything that
is as close to beating the casino
besides poker
no uh no probably focus poker is the one
and stay away from
in general everything else i do know
there are professional sports bettors
who
make a living at it this is a select
group of people some of the people who
you might find out there who are telling
you they've got the picks and just pay
me x amount whatever those typically
aren't the guys who are winning they're
making the money off selling selling the
picks yep and not their actual bets and
you'll notice they don't typically show
you their tickets if you don't see
somebody showing you they bet on the
game and now i'm giving you that pick
you bet on the game they don't show you
the ticket
i wouldn't i don't really trust them you
know and so sports betting is possible
but you gotta do your research and uh
extremely difficult there's a handful of
probably people who really make good
money at it it's that difficult so we
got a clips exclusive here just
available on the iced coffee hour clips
channel
and i asked this question it was good
enough to be featured here so
does it exist in a casino where you see
in the movies where they take you back
into the back room and there's like a
dimly lit room and they put you down on
a chair there's like you know a few big
guys behind you and they kind of shake
you just does that exist yeah uh this
did happen to me um yeah i guess i'll
just admit it i'll tell you the full
story okay and technically i committed a
felony
so while i was sitting here i was
researching your
amazing acting career
and i saw that
you were on an episode of icarly
that's right
can you tell us a little bit about that
because we we just had jeanette mccurdy
on a few episodes ago oh yeah so the
episode was i stage an intervention and
i was playing a geek which
was in my wheelhouse i played the nerd a
lot
and so
i remember
um
i originally had one line
and i came in jeanette by the way so
cool everybody on set was fun and it was
a great time but we had rehearsal days
and so i went from one line the first
day to two lines the second day and then
i picked up more so by the time we shot
the episode i had whatever i had for
like i forget how many i had but it i it
kept getting merged and they were like
oh you got new dialogue today and i was
like where's so and so and they were
like not here not coming back
so you got to be on point okay this is
what i talked about how
it's good to be good i mean to take it
that seriously no matter how small your
role is they're looking for you to be to
deliver and the more you deliver and
other people don't you could reap the
rewards and hey i mean you know sucks
for that like it's sort of like it was
totally out of my control but at the
same time you're going great i mean
picking up more lines so it was fun um
yeah that was a a definitely a great set
to be on and to this day everybody knows
icarly so that's a fun one to mention
like if i want to mention stuff i was on
i would say that or i say even stevens
another good one
and one more thing you know i want to
mention you guys should go and check out
the family vlog channel because anthony
came and we vlogged it and he pulled up
in a
ferrari
f430 now you might have noticed i kind
of said
ferrari a little weird
uh i'll say it slower
fo
rari there it is like a like a foe it's
a fake why'd you say it like that it's a
replica it's a replica
yeah
anthony purchased a fake ferrari f430
that was built off of a uh what was it
toyota celica yeah gcs
and it's parked in the driveway right
now it looks from the back exactly like
a ferrari 430. so if you guys want to
see it go and subscribe to the family
channel in the description you're going
to see anthony pull up in this thing
it's what it listen it'll fool you from
100 feet away it looks exactly like
everybody gets a laugh out of it so 25
000.
why why did you buy the ferrari because
you because you have a real lamborghini
yeah you got to be eccentric i guess
i'll just own it i'm not going to say
crazy yeah i'm eccentric okay
so yeah everybody who owns a kit car
they're a little bit off
all right i'll just accept it
so it was just for the for the lols or
yeah just you know you get bored what
else are you gonna do with your time by
fake exotic
so with that said you guys thank you so
much for watching i really appreciate it
anthony thank you so much for coming on
today thank you guys embracing us with
your wisdom
on everything i really appreciate it now
one big important announcement here
public reached out to me the other day
it's big
they've now raised how much you can get
from a free stock
from what to 70
all the way up to
thousand dollars
you can now get a stock worth all the
way up to a thousand dollars
yeah so if you haven't done that already
you may as well use the link in the
description oh in order to do that you
have to use the code gram
that's it you use the code gram and
that'll apply incredible so enjoy the
free stock let us know which one you get
uh the clips channel is also down below
in the description all of our instagrams
all of our instagrams go and follow
unofficial anthony on youtube he's
posting the ferrari
on there oh yeah and with that said you
guys until next time
and we'll just have a conversation for
an hour okay cool
well